اكثر من 100 ساعه تلاشى بعدها الامل شيئا
فشيئا بالوصول الى نجين خاصه في ظل البرد
القارس عدد القتلى ارتفع الى نحو 25 الف
شخص في كل من تركيا وسوريا في تركيا وبحسب
وزير الصحه التركيه تجاوز عدد القتلى 20
الف قتيل واكثر من 80 الف مصاب اما في
سوريا فاعلنا المرصد السوري ان حصيله
القتلى وصلت الى اربعه الاف وخمسمائه وهي
مرشحه للوصول الى سته الاف في مناطق اعلنت
اليوم منكوبه وهي حلب اللاذقيه حماه وادلب
حجم الكارثه في هذه المناطق يفوق قدره
الجميع بحسب منظمه الصحه العالميه
[موسيقى]
متى تحت الانقاض اكثر من اربعه ايام ونصف
لكنه خرج على قيد الحياه بعدما تم انقاذه
اليكم مشاهدينا هذه الصور المؤثره للحظه
اخراج طفل وهو حي يرزق في جبله بمحافظه
اللاذقيه في سوريا
[موسيقى]
طالعين
يا
رورو يا
عبودي يا الله
تمكنت فرق الدفاع المدني في جبله في
اللاذقيه من انقاذ ام واولادها الثلاثه من
تحت مبنى منهار شاهدوا
[تصفيق]
العثور على احد الاشخاص وهو على قيد
الحياه الف الحمد لله
الحمد لله
الف الحمد لله
[تصفيق]
شو اسمه شو اسمه
شو اسمه يا شباب شو اسمه شو اسمه
شو اسمه الف الحمد لله على السلامه
ابراهيم زكريا
وبعد 108 ساعات تحت الانقاض تمكن رجال
لانقاذ الاتراك من انقاذ رجل في ولايه
هاتاي
[موسيقى]
تمام تمام
الله
[موسيقى]
اكدت فرق الطوارئ في سوريا ان العديد من
المنازل في مدينه حلب التي تلقت الضربه
الاكثر ايلاما من الزلزال تضررت بشكل كبير
او انهار تماما وبحسب الفرق لا يزال
الكثير من السكان عالقين تحت انقاض
البنايات في حلب التي يقيم فيها ملايين
اللاجئين الذين تشردوا بعدما افقدتهم
الحرب الاهليه منازلهم
[موسيقى]
وفيما تتضاءل فرص الوصول الى ناجينا بعد
مرور نحو سته ايام على زلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب جنوب تركيا تواصل فرق الانقاذ عمليات
البحث في مدينه كهرما مرعش مركز الزلزال
على امل انقاذ ما يمكن انقذه في اللحظه
الاخيره غسان بولس
هنا مركز زلزال هنا كهرمان مرعش حيث
الانقاض حبلى بالقتله والعالقين هنا انقاذ
وانتظار وكثير من البكاء
وفي المشهد ستيني ينتظر ولاده ابنه من فم
الموت
ابني هنا وعائلته مكونه من سته اشخاص
اخرجوا شخصا واحدا فقط على قيد الحياه
والاعمال مستمره لانقاذهم ولا معلومات
عنهم حتى الان
وفي هذا الحي سوريون هربوا من ويلات الحرب
قبل سنوات هربوا من الموت الى موت اخر
والله ان ثلاثه اشخاص تحت الانقاذ صار لنا
شي يومين لسه ما طلعنا منهم اي خبر او اي
نتيجه منهم في كهرمان مرعش اختلطت الدماء
تحت انقاض اكثر من 940 بنايه سويت بالارض
تمر ساعات والايام وتتضاءل فرص نجاه
العالقين وفي الذاكره صور لاحبه حجم
الكارثه فاق زلزال مرمره عام 99 والصوره
كافيه واصدقوا انباء وفي الصوره ايضا يمكن
نقل اعداد الموتى والجرحى والمصابين
والدمار والدموع لكن وحدها رائحه الموت
على امتداد 10 ولايات لا يمكن نقلها
العربيه كهرمان مرعش
[موسيقى]
بلغت جهود وانقاذ المفقودين في الزلزال
الذي ضرب اجزاء واسعه من تركيا وسوريا
يومها
التكاد تبلغ يومها السادس وبينما يسابق
المنقذون الزمن من اجل العثور على احياء
لا زالت الجهود تثمر بحالات شكل صمودها
مفاجاه بسبب درجات الحراره المنخفضه التي
تشهدها المنطقه
اخيرا صيحه الالم احيت امال المنقذين في
بلده جنديرس السوريه دقائق معدوده واسيا
البالغه من العمر 10 سنوات تغادر الجحيم
بعد 90 ساعه قضت تحت الركعه
بدون اكل ولا شرب وفي درجات حراره متجمده
اليوم الخامس بعد الزلزال المعجزات ما
زالت تتحقق
في الليله نفسها حفر عمال الانقاذ لساعات
بايادي عاريه
هزه ارتداديه جديده كافيه لاعادتهم لنقطه
الصفر
تجلى الغبار واستقبلت الفتاه بالتصفيق
وجوه بريئه تحولت الى رمز للصمود اما
شجاعتهم فقد الهمت الموقنين
عائلات اخرى كانت اكثر حظا
انقذت البنت
ساعتين من بعدها التحق الاب رغم الصدمه
يمسك بشده بيد منقذه كلمه الاولى ترجمه
مشاعره
ناصر بقي يقظا لايام وكان شهيدا على اخراج
افراد عائلته الواحده والاخر
كتبت الحياه لثلاثه ابناء الا ان الام
غادرت مع البقيه خروجها من تحت الركام لم
يدم طويلا عاد ناصر برفقه فريق الانقاذ
لدفنها غير بعيد عن مكان بيته
اطلعت قلت يا ربي بس سلم لي واحد بدي واحد
بس منها الاولاد من شفت طلعت وما ناديت
فيصل ناديت مشعل محسن منصور ما حدا رد
قلت ما وصلوا معناته ماتوا
صور حيه للمعجزات لكن كم من الاتراك
والسوريين لم يسعفوا الحظ
فرق الانقاذ في سباق مع الساعه مرور الوقت
يعني املا اقل اجواء متجمده وهزات
ارتداديه تعيق المهمه
اما من كتبت لهم الحياه فعليهم خوضوا
معركه صمود جديده
نتابع الان من ريف ادلب مع الصحفي محمد
الاشقر محمد اهلا بك معنا هل تلاشت تماما
اي فرص الان في العثور على ناجين
نعم يعني في الحقيقه بحسب مدير الدفاع
المدني السوري السيد رائد الصالح فقد تحدث
على
محمد
ماذا قال عذرا محمد صوتك تقطع بسبب
الارسال هلا قعدت الفكره رجاء
نعم نعم
تفضل نعم كنت اتحدث على ان السيد رائد
الصالح مدير الدفاع المدني السوري قد تحدث
على ان فرص انقاذ ضحايا احياء من تحت
الانقاض باتت شبه معدومه وخصوصا بعد مرور
هذا الوقت نحن ساعات قليله تفصلون عن دخول
اليوم السادس لبدء هذه الكارثه التي ضربت
سوريا وتركيا طبعا جميع من يتم انتشالهم
الان هم ضحايا يتم انتشال
ولكن ان تركتني ان اتحدث قليلا عن الاهالي
الذين ينتظرون ذويهم في محيط الابنيه التي
يتم العمل فيها على انتشار
والله يا محمد انا اريدك ان تتحدث وان
تنقل اكبر قدر من المعلومات شبه معدوم
ولكن ارسال يتقطعت تفضل الان اسمعك الان
يصلني صوتك
نعم نعم كنت اتحدث على ان الاهالي يعيشون
املا ولو كان ضئيلا في محيط الابنيه التي
يتم العمل فيها على انتشار الضحايا
عندما عندما يتم العثور على احد الضحايا
تحت الانقاض يبدا الصراخ وتتهافت الناس
والاهالي باتجاه مكان وجود الضحيه
يعني بامل على ان هذه الضحيه ما زالت حيه
ولكن للاسف تكون عباره عن جثمان لشخص
متوفي اليوم جميع
الاشخاص الذين تم انتشال جثثها من تحت
الانقاط كانوا لاشخاص متوفين ان سمحت لي
ان اتحدث عن بلغه الارقام من هذه المنطقه
التي اتواجد بها الان كمثال بسيط نحن الان
في منطقه بسنيا في
يحتوي على 123 شقه دمرت بشكل كامل بحسب
شهود العيان من اهل القريه فقط قالوا ان
اعداد الناجين من تحت هذه الانقاض كانت
فقط سبعه وعشرين شخصا اماما تبقى جميعهم
تم انتشالهم
وهمم اموات تعرضوا للوفاه نتيجه هذا هذا
الزلزال يعني الى حد هذه اللحظه يعني هذه
هذا الحي السكني البسيط لا توجد فيه
احصائيه دقيقه حول اعداد القتلى نتيجه هذا
الزلزال طبعا غياب الاحصائيه الدقيقه هو
لعده عوامل وعده اسباب لعل ابرزها انتشار
بقعه
المناطق التي
تعرضت لهذه الكارثه وهي اكثر من 66
نعم محمد شكرا جزيلا لك على العموم يعني
كنت ان اريد ان اخذ منك المزيد من
المعطيات ولكن
الارسال يتقطع ولكن صوتك وصل والرساله
وصلت شكرا جزيلا لك محمد الاشقر مباشره من
في محاولاتها تقوم بالانقاذ البحث عن
ناجينه تحت الانقاض برزت عده طرق تستخدمها
هذه الفرق اكثر من غيرها نتعرف عليها مع
مراسلنا من اضنه جنوب تركيا
في المواقع المدمره نتيجه الزلزال الذي
ضرب تركيا تعتمد فرق الانقاذ على عده طرق
للتاكد مما اذا كان هناك ناجين تحت
الانقاض ام لا اولا الطريقه التقليديه
التي يقوم من خلالها احد رجال الانقاذ
باصدار نداءات متكرره بعد فتح فجوه بين
الركام وينتظر حتى يسمع ردا من الداخل في
حال لم يصله رد تلجا الفرق الى الطريقه
الثانيه وهي الكلاب المدربه التي تستشعر
وجود احياء كذلك تلجا فرق الانقاذ الى
استخدام كاميرات المراقبه الحراريه التي
تستطيع تحديد اماكن العالقين تحت الانقاض
طبعا نحن نصور هذا التقرير بعد انتهاء
تطبيق هذه الطرق لان الصمت والهدوء التام
شرط اساسي لنجاح هذه الطرق زيدان زنكلو
اضنه
اكدت فرق الطوارئ في سوريا ان العديد من
المنازل في مدينه حلب التي تلقت الضربه
الاكثر ايلاما من الزلزال تضررت بشكل كبير
او انهارت تماما وبحسب الفرق لا يزال
الكثير من السكان عالقين تحت انقاض
البنايات في حلب التي يقيم فيها ملايين
اللاجئين الذين تشردوا بعدما افقدتهم
الحرب الاهليه منازلهم
[موسيقى]
من اضنه معنا زيدان زين كلو مراسل العربيه
زيدان انقل لنا الصوره من عندك ماذا يحدث
الان وهل تلاشت الامال تقريبا في العثور
على اي ناجين بعد كل هذا الوقت
نعم صهيب اعمال الانقاذ ما تزال مستمره
وعمليات البحث بين الركام وتحت الانقاذ
عنا جين لا تزال مستمره رغم انقضاء هذا
الوقت الطويل صهيب لكن ما يزال هناك بعض
الامل لدى رجال الانقاذ قبل قليل تم
انتشال جثه جديده من هذا الموقع الذي
نتواجد فيه الان يعني حتى الان لا توجد
انباء
توحي بان هناك اشخاص ما زالوا احياء تحت
الانقاض لكن فريقنا الخبراء يواصل البحث
في هذا الموقع الذي نتواجد فيه الان في
وسط مدينه اضنه املا في العثور على
الناجين حقيقه يعني صهيب كلما اتى خبر من
احدى الولايات حتى لو كانت بعيده جدا
بالعثور على شخص ما زال على قيد الحياه
بعد 100 ساعه او بعد 180 ساعات هذا يعطي
دفعه معنويه اضافيه لفرق الانقاذ الموجوده
هنا في اضنه وايضا لفرق الموجوده في بقيه
المواقع لذلك ترى ان عمليات البحث رغم ان
الوقت يمضي وفرص البقاء الاشخاص العالقين
تحت الارض على قيد الحياه تتضاءل لكن مع
ذلك الجميع لا يستسلم ويحاولون
للحظات الاخيره في الاستمرار بعمليات
البحث بكل الطرق الممكنه
للحفاظ على حياه الاشخاص اذا ما كانوا على
قيد الحياه تحت الانقاض في هذا المبنى
يعني وكما علمنا صهيب تم انتشار او تم
العثور على خمسه اشخاص كانوا على قيد
الحياه في اليوم الاول والثاني مع الاسف
حاله اثنين منهما حرجه وهم
يتعالجون وهما يتعالجان في مشفى اضنا هنا
في احد مشافي اضنه الثلاثه الباقيين
حالتهم جيده وهم ايضا يتلقون علاج لكم لكن
هم في حاله جيده وهذه طبعا كانت اخبار
ايجابيه من هذا الموقع لكن
رغم ذلك هذا المساء شهدنا ومنذ وصولنا الى
هنا انتشار عده جثث من هذا الموقع يعني
اخبار احيانا سلبيه دائما مع استمرار
عمليات البحث والانقاذ دائما يكون هناك
انتشار للجثث لكن دائما كل من في هذا
الموقع ينتظر خبرا ايجابيا ربما ولو كان
شخصا واحدا اذا خرج على قيد الحياه فهذا
سيكلل جهود الجميع بالنجاح والجميع يعلم
ان يعلم ان جهوده لم تذهب سدا وتمكنوا ولو
من انقاذ شخص واحد شخص واحد يعني هو مكسب
لكل هذه العمليه فما بالك اذا عثروا على
اكثر من شخص صهيب لذلك العمليات تستمر في
وتيره عاليه هناك محاوله حديثه في هذه
الولايه السلطات في هذه الولايه تريد
انهاء العمل بسرعه هنا ولكن العمل
ما هي الخطه ما هي الخطه الان نتحدث عن
تجاوزنا 180 ساعات منذ الزلزال طبعا يبقى
الامل موجود ولكن فرصه العثور على ناجين
يعني تبقى تتضاءل شيئا فشيئا الى ان تنعدم
ما هي الخطه الان الموضوع الان بعد يعني
مرور المزيد من الوقت
كيف سيتم التعامل مع كل هذا الدمار زيدان
نعم صهيب انا كنت اسال احد عناصر الانقاذ
او احد عناصر طواقم الانقاذ ما هي المده
المتوقعه وهي المده الطبيعيه للبحث عن
ناجين في الحالات الاعتياديه في الكوارث
اخبرني ان مده البحث يجب ان تتراوح ما بين
خمسه الى ايام الى سبعه ايام هذه هي المده
الطبيعيه اقلها خمسه ايام واكثرها سبعه
ايام
لكن اخبرني انه حاليا نهايه اليوم الخامس
بالضبط
نعم نعم لكن لكن في بعض الحالات اخبرني ان
هناك حالات وهي تكون هنا ندخل في الحالات
النادره وهو ما يسموه هنا المعجزات تصل
بعض الحالات في لمده ثلاثه عشر يوما ربما
في هذه حتى هذه المده يمكن ان يصمد
الانسان اذا كانت صحته جيده ولم يكن قد
تعرض اثناء الانهيارات
لاضرار بجسده وكان جسده سليما معافى وكانت
صحته بالاساس جيده يمكن ان يصمد لمده
اقصاها 13 يوما لكن هذا بحسب ما اخبرني به
احد المنقذين احتمال بسيط جدا لكنه موجود
حول العالم وجرى في عده كوارث او حصل في
عده كوارث جرت في اكثر من بقاء حول حول
العالم
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه الصوره الحيه زيدان
من اضنه
في حديثها للعربيه اكدت المتحدثه باسم
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي في الشرق الاوسط
الحاجه الماسه لفتح المعابر السوريه
لتسهيل ايصال المساعدات للمتضررين من
الزلزال هناك مخزون يكفي لمئه الف شخص وج
بات لا تحتاج الى طه تكفي لمده اسبوع
وهناك مخزون يكفي الى يكفي مليون ونصف شخص
ولكنها حصص غذائيه شهريه ولكن تحتاج الى
الطه بالنسبه لدخول المساعدات نحن نستخدم
ممر باب الهوى نحن نستخدم المعابر في داخل
سوريا ولكن بسبب يعني بسبب الزلزال
والدمار الطرقات
مدمره ولذلك هناك بطء لذلك
ندعو الى فتح مزيد من الممرات هذا كان
هناك باب السلام يدخل منه تدخل منه
المساعدات فقط البطء البطء الوصول بسبب
الدمار في المنطقه
هذا وقالت منظمه الصحه العالميه ان
الزلزال اعاد الى الواجهه ما وصفته
بالازمه المنسيه في سوريا واكدت انها
مستعده لارسال مساعدات كبيره الى هذا
البلد لكنها تواجه الكثير من القيود
واضافت الصحه العالميه ان حجم الكارثه في
سوريا كبير للغايه ويفوق قدره الجميع
واشارت الصحه العالميه الى ان الزلزال
الذي دمر اجزاء كبيره من المدن في سوريا
اعاد تسليط الضوء على سوريا التي تعاني
اصلا
قال المدير الاقليمي لجمعيات الصليب
الاحمر والهلال الاحمر لمنطقه الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا حسام شرقاوي في لقاء
مع العربيه ان الاوضاع في الشمال السوري
صعبه داعيا في الوقت ذاته الى تنحيه
السياسه جانبا والتركيز على ايصال
المساعدات لكل سوريا في مناطق فيها وضع
امني حساس في مناطق وصلتها المعونات وهذا
يدور 24 ساعه
الوضع ماساوي كما كل التقارير تفيد وبدات
تظهر حجم الدمار
نحس الجميع انه نحط السياسه على جنب ونركز
على انقاذ الناس وتقديم المعونه
تواصلوا فرقه لانقاذ الدوليه عملها في
المناطق المتضرره في تركيا وسوريا ومن
الفرق المستمره في العمل على الارض فريق
الانقاذ الاردني الذي يضم 99 منقذه متخصصا
واطباء من الخدمات الطبيه الملكيه والذي
انضم لفرق انقاذ من عده دول حول العالم
تعمل الان على الارض في كل من سوريا
وتركيا
في ادلب التقطت كاميرا العربيه صورا تظهر
حجم الدمار هناك نتابع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حضرت لجنه الانقاذ الدوليه من انهيار
الصحه العامه في شمال غرب سوريا مع اتضاح
اثار الزلزال المدمر وقالت اللجنه في بيان
ان الاضرار الكبيره التي لحقت بالمرافق
الصحيه التي تعاني بالفعل من الضغوط
الشديده والبنيه التحتيه الحيويه مثل
الطرق والجسور تعني ان النظام الصحي الذي
تضرر بشده بالفعل بعد 12 عاما من الصراع
اصبح الان يترنح تحت ضغط الطلب المتزايد
على الخدمه
المدير التنفيذي لبرنامج الطوارئ بمنظمه
الصحه العالميه ان العالم كان قد نسي
سوريا لكن الزلزال اعاد الانتباه الى
الازمه هناك
الان لفت الزلزال الانتباه لكن العالم نسي
سوريا بصراحه اعاد الزلزال الانتباه لكن
هؤلاء الملايين من الناس في سوريا يكافحون
منذ السنوات واصبحوا في ازمه منسيه لذلك
في الواقع ومن المفارقات ان الزلزال هو
ماساه مروعه ولكنه يعيد الانتباه على
الاقل الى الاحتياجات الاوسعي للسكان
نشرت الامم المتحده تغريده ذكرت فيها ان
المفوضه السامي لحقوق الانسان بولكارتورك
طالب بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار في سوريا
وذلك لتسهيل ايصال المساعدات الى ضحايا
الزلزال الذي دمر قسما من البلاد كما طالب
باحترام حقوق الانسان بهدف تقليل اثار
الازمه الحاليه التي اصابت
تحضيرات امميه من انهيار صحي وكارثه جديده
تتمثل بفقدان الارواح بسبب نقص المعدات
الطبيه اللازمه في شمال غرب سوريا
بعد ان تحولت اجزاء كبيره من شمال سوريا
بطرفه عين الى مناطق منكوبه بقيت
المساعدات الدوليه خجوله لا تليق بحجم
اكبر زلزال تم تسجيله على اليابسه يقتل
المعهد الايطالي للجيو فيزياء خمسه ملايين
وثلا شخص اصبح مشردين بلا ماوى في سوريا
بسبب الزلزال رقم كبير قدرته المفوضيه
اللاجئين التابعه للامم المتحده المناطق
المنكوبه هنا في الشمال السوري دفعت لجنه
الايقاظ الدوليه الى تحذير من انهيار
الصحه العامه وسط تحذيرات من كارثه جديده
بعد الزلزال تتمثل بفقدان الارواح بسبب
نقص المعدات الطبيه اللازمه وفق منظمه
الصحه العالميه هذا الامر اشتكى منهم
مستشفى ادلب واكد ان طاقته لا تستوعب
العدد الكبير من المصابين اضافه الى نقص
حاد في المواد الطبيه والاجهزه
بشكل عام ووضعهم سيء جدا بحاجه الى رعايه
طبيه فائقه بحاجه الى اجهزه بحاجه
لمستهلكات ادويه
لطاقتك كانت تكفي للتعامل مع هذا العدد
الكبير من الاصابات تحذير الامم الاخر
اطلقته يونس اعربت عن مخاوفها من ارتفاع
عدد مرضى الكوليرا في سوريا نتيجه تعرض
شبكه المياه الى الدمار بسبب الزلزال ورغم
هذا المشهد الماساوي تاخر وصول المساعدات
لتدخل اول قافله للامم المتحده بعد ايام
على الكارثه مؤلفه من 20 شاحنه فقط ضمت
معدات انسانيه وخياما وبطانيات لكنها
خاليه من اي مواد غذائيه واخرى ضروريه
لعمليه البحث والانقاذ
توعد الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
باتخاذ اجراءات عقابيه قاسيه بحق ما
يهاجمون الاسواق والمحلات التجاريه
وينهبون السلع والمواد منها
مباني مدمره محلات تساوت بالارض والاخرى
بقيت صامده عدا نوافذها المحطمه يتسابق من
بقي في هذه المدن المتضرره من الزلزال الى
اكوام من الصناديق البعض بحثا عن
الاحتياجات الاساسيه واخرون استغلوا الوضع
الصعب للسرقه والنهب هنا نرى من يخرج
راكضا من محل تجاري بيده اساسيات غذائيه
او استهلاكيه وبالمقابل مشهد لاخرين
يخرجون اما خليل وفاض او بغنائمه كبيره
مهما كانت اسبابه ومبرراته اولئك الاشخاص
الذين وثقت سرقاتهم عبر مقاطع فيديو ملات
مواقع التواصل الا ان الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان اكد انه لهم بالمرصاد مستنكرا
استغلال البعض للظروف الصعبه الحاليه
مع الاسف هناك بعض الناس الذين يهاجمون
الاسواق والمحلات التجاريه وينهب والمواد
الدوله اتخذت التدابير وخطوات ضدها هؤلاء
وستتم معاقبتهم باشد الطرق الرئيس التركي
اعلن قبل ايام حاله الطوارئ في البلاد
لمده ثلاثه اشهر حاله قال انها ستساهم في
مساعده المدن المنكوبه والحد من اعمال
النهب والسرقه
روان حمزه العربيه
معنى من اسطنبول المحلل
اهلا بك معنا طبعا الى اضافه الى هذه
المظاهر السلبيه لسرقه المحلات
هناك ايضا برزت كذلك مساله سرقه المساعدات
الموجهه
للسوريين كذلك بالنسبه للاراضي السوريه
كيف يمكن تفسير يعني هذه المظاهر السلبيه
فيها هكذا ازمه كبيره في هكذا كارثه
انسانيه هذه الظروف يكون هناك من يذهب
بهذا الاتجاه باتجاه السرقه والنهب
نعم يعني هناك نسمه ونرى اعمال السرقه
والنهب ولكن ليست على
على
ظاهره لا يمكن نعمل نطاق واسع ليس على
نطاق واسع هناك حاله فرديه وفي حالات
اعتقد يعني تبقى في حالات فرديه
محطوطه ولد الحكومه جميع الصلاحيات بموجب
بموجب قرار حاله الطوارئ لدى السلطات
الامنيه تم
نشر الجيش
بالاضافه الى وحدات الشرطه
كذلك تم نشر الجهه اعتقد يتم التغلب على
هذه المشكله باسرع وقت ممكن لان لا نتحدث
عن حاله
واسعه ظاهره كبيره فقط في اطار محطوط جدا
يجب ان تنتهي بكل التاكيد لا لا يمكن يعني
الحديث في كل المجتمعات توجد مثل هؤلاء
الاشخاص
يحاولون الاستغلال من الفاظ السيء ليس
تبريرا طبعا هذا الشيء لا يبرر طبعا خاصه
في هكذا
وضع
ولكن هناك من يرى بان يعني الظروف الصعبه
بالنسبه للناس بعد ان فقدت كل شيء يعني
تدفعهم ربما للسرقه هذا طبعا ليس تبرير
ولكن هل ترى ان السلطات التركيه يعني
قامت بتوفير ما يلزم للمتضررين من الزلزال
يا سيدي الكريم يعني السؤال الاول هل
استنفرت السلطات جميع الامكانياتها وسخرت
جميع الامكانياتها واستنفرت لنجده
المنكوبين صحيح ولكن هل كافيه هذه الجهود
خاصه في الايام الاولى لا نظرا
لمصعه
المناطق المنكوبه نتحدث عن مساحه كبيره
وملايين من الناس وعشرات الالاف من
الابنيه
محتمه خاصه اليوم الاول كان في اليوم
الاول كان مشاكل كبيره والصعوبات حتى في
الوصول الى الناس يعني تشكيل الفرق
والوصول الى المناطق المنكوبه اخذت وقتا
وكانت هناك تاخر وكانت هناك خلل والمشاكل
اقره اردوغان بنفسه ولكن خاصه بعد اليوم
الثاني والثالث تحسن الورد الى كبير يعني
بالاضافه الى
المؤسسات الرسميه هناك مؤسسات المجتمع
المدني المتطورين
المتطوعين من الخارج
والمساعدات يعني كانها تمطر الى المنطقه
اذا كان الشخص يحتاج الى الماء الى الخبز
وياخذه في المكان المحدد هذا في لا يعتبر
سرقه هذا هذا حقه نحن نتحدث عن النهب نهب
بباطئ الاسواق وما الى ذلك هذا يجب ان
يواجه بكل القسوه والشده هذا النائب ولكن
اخذ
سرقه نظرا لوصول لبعض المواد الى باطل
مناطق متاخرا وهذا امر طبيعي طبعا والمهمه
ليست سهله طبعا اكيد يعني هي كارثه كبرى
نشاهد جميعا حجم الدمار يعني نقدر الظرف
الصعب بالنظر النائب رئيس كان قال ان
السلطات تركيه تستضيف نحو مليون وخمسين
الف مواطن من متضرري الزلزال في مراكز
ايواء انا اريد ان اسالك يعني صحيحا الان
في نهايه اليوم الخامس بعد الزلزال ربما
الوقت ما يزال مبكرا ولكن كيف ترى مالات
هذه الكارثه او تسيير ما بعد هذه
الكارثه كيف يمكن الخروج من من مشاهد
الدمار هذه
يعني للاسف الشديد الخروج سوف من هذا
المشهد المؤلم لن تكون سهله
خاصه نحن في ما زلنا في المرحله الاولى من
من البعث والانقاذ وما زالت في رايي عشرات
الالاف تحت الانقاذ للاسف الشديد الحصول
او الوصول اليهم حيا يعني امر
تكاته مستحيلا
وتتضائل
الفرص
ستكون عدد الضحايا اكبر بكثير مما علم
اليوم للاسف الشديد هذا هو الباقي بعد ذلك
تاتي فتره
ازاله وتطهير المناطق المنكوبه لتبدا
الحكومه طبعا على الاقل البادئ في في بناء
المساكن على الاقل المؤقته
والمتنقله يعني
استغ الناس استغاثه استغاثه استغاثتهم
بالحاجات الاساسيه
وايضا واغاثتهم ونقل
الحاجات يعني امر
صعب جدا كذلك ولكن يعني الحكومه
قطمت
وجميع صخرت جميع امكاناتها بالاضافه هناك
عقيقه تضامن كبير ممتاز جدا من المجتمع
الدولي كان هناك نتحدث عن عشرات اكثر من
60 طوال ارسلت فروق الانقاذ وما زالت
المساعدات تصل البنك الدولي
سترسل حوالي 200 مليار دولار كالطعم
الاولى كذلك ستكون هناك طعم دولي تركيا
عاشت تجارب
سابقه ليس في نفس المستوى الصحيح ولكن
هناك هناك تجربه زلزال المرمره الكبير
ستتم تجاوز هذه المحنه كذلك ولكن لن تكون
الامر سهله
سنوات وسنوات وسنوات نتحدث عن حوالي اربعه
اشهر مليون شخص تعرضوا لهذه النكبه لهذه
الكارثه شكرا جزيلا لكم
استاذي من اسطنبول
وصلت مطار غازي عنتاب في تركيا اليوم
الطائرتان الاغاثيتان الرابع والخامسه
السعوديه
وتقلان فريق البحث والانقاذ السعودي مع
جميع التجهيزات التي يحتاجها من الاليات
والمعدات والمضخات والادويه الطبيه
والتجهيزه الفنيه للمساهمه في جهود انقاذ
ضحايا زلزال عبد المحسن الحربي
وصل في هذه الاثناء الى مطار غازي عنتاب
الفريق الفريق الانقاذ السعودي المكون من
مختصا في عمليات الانقاذ في مختلف
التخصصات بالاضافه الى تخصصات طبيه دقيقه
تتعامل مع حالات الاحتجاز هذا الفريق
الطبي
الفريق الانقاذ المكون من مختلف تخصصات
بالاضافه الى فريق طبي سيبدا في العمل في
غازي عنتاب وفي المناطق المتضرره الاخرى
مباشره
ومساعده كافه السلطات التي تعمل على سلطات
الانقاذ التي تعمل على رفع
الاجزاء من المنازل المهدمه والمتضرره
جراءه الزلزال والتي ستباشر بتنسيق مع
السلطات التركيه ومختلف القطاعات المختلفه
العامله في هذه الازمه جراء الزلزال عبد
المحسن الحربي العربيه
مطار غازي عنتاب
اعربت رئيسه لجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
عن دهشتها من حجم الدمار الذي اصاب مدينه
حلب كما اكدت ان الصليب الاحمر سيبذل كل
ما في وسعه لتقديم الدعم لمن هم في حاجه
اليها
من الصعب جدا وصف المعاناه والدمار الذين
شهدتهما هنا في حلب الطقس بارد جدا ولا
توجد تدفئه قلبي ينفطر على كل من فقد
احبائه والاباء الذين فقدوا اطفالهم
والاطفال الذين فقدوا ذويهم من الصعب رؤيه
معاناه الاطفال وكبار السن بشكل خاص ستبذل
اللدنه الدوليه كلما في وسعها لدعمهم
وطالبت رئيسه لجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
بعدم عرقله العمل الانساني وعدم تاسيس
المساعدات الانسانيه المواجهه للمتضررين
جراء الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا واضافت في
تصريح عقب زياره قادتها الى حلب ان صليب
الاحمر سيبذل قصار جهده لدعم الناس اينما
كانوا الا ان مع جميع الاطراف الى ساحه
الوصول الكامل للمساعدات الانسانيه
[موسيقى]
هذا هو حذرت منظمه اليونيسف من مخاطر
انتشار واسع للامراض المنقوله بواسطه
المياه عقب الزلزال المدمر في تركيا
وسوريا في وقت يثير فيه نقص الوقود
والكهرباء والمياه النظيفه مخاوف جمعيات
الاغاثه الخيريه وفق موقع اكسبرس البريط
من نجا من فك الزلزال به وبمنزله قد لا
ينجو من كارثه صحيه تتربص به الكوليرا عدو
اخر يهدد سوريا وتركيا
ناقوس الخطر دقته منظمه اليونيسف التي
حذرت من مخاطر انتشار واسع للامراض
المنقوله بواسطه المياه حيث تبقى مخاطر
الاصابه بامراض مثل الكوليرا
والاسهالتاريا في اعلى مستوياتها على
الاطلاق في اعقاب كارثه الزلزال في سوريا
تم اعلان تفشي الكوليرا قبل خمسه اشهر في
عقب الزلزال ربما تكون مصادر المياه
النظيفه القليل المتاحه قد تضررت ايضا
قلق عالمي يتزايد اذا انتشار وباء
الكوليرا الذي ظهر مجددا في سوريا
والارقام تحكي عن رصد 84 الف حاله منذ
سبتمبر الماضي حتى بدايه هذا العام
المعطيات وفق المنظمات الصحيه تشير الى
ازدياد الحالات ان لم تتم معالجه الشبكات
المتضرره بالسرعه الممكنه
الحال نفسها في تركيا وان كانت بدرجات اقل
المياه غمرت شوارع بعض المناطق المتضرره
من الزلزال
وسط تقارير غربيه تشير الى نقص حاد في
المياه الصالحه للشرب في تلك المناطق
الامر الذي يضاعف الخسائر وينذر بكارثه
صحيه اخرى قبل الاستفاقه من صدمه الكارثه
الزلزال
ورغم تضاؤل حظوظ اخراج ناجينا من تحت
الانقاب بمرور خمسه ايام على الزلزال
المدمر لم يفقد الشاب السوري سامر المتطوع
في فرق الانقاذ لم يفقد الامل في العثور
على صديقه المفقود تحت انقاض بلده جنديرس
شمالي سوريا ما حدا بيعرف فينا شيء خالص
خالص هنا بجنديرس شمالي سوريا حيث النصيب
الاكبر من الكارثه المتطوعون من اهالي
البلده كان وحدهم من جابها هولا الزلزال
اليومين قبل انضمام فرق الانقاذ قليله
العدد شحيحه المعدات
طالما عالم عايشين طارن عالم ميتين
بايدينا بحثنا بايدينا كريكات
بالعصي بالبواري ايش نلاقي قدامنا نعزل
طالعنا عايشين طلعنا ميتين
ضلينا لثاني يوم لحتى هون
اجا الدفاع المدني اجوا اجوا العالم
تساعدنا في جنديرس قصه البحث عن الناجينه
تاخذ معنى اخر
سامر الذي انقذ العشرات منذ اربعه ايام
انهكه التعب لكن انامله لم تتوقف عن البحث
فشخص عزيز عليه تحت هذا الركام رفيق دربه
وابن حارته المدمره ما يزال في عداد
المفقودين اول بنايه وصل عليها
البنايه اللي ساكن فيها رفيقي رفيقي اسمه
علي اول ما وصلت
لحد الان هذا ثالث يوم رابع يوم انا هون
يعني اهلي ما بعرف عنه غير انه اوصل بس
اشوفه انه عايشين وارجع فقط لا غير
ضلينا نبحث لحد الان
[تصفيق]
متطوعوه جنديرس لا يحتاجون الى قوائم
المفقودين فهم يعرفون من قضى نحبه ومن
ينتظر وهذا الجهد المتواصل بالنسبه اليهم
هو الواجب اتجاه الاهل والوفاء قبل
التضامن علمنا اعز رفقاتي ابو قلب الطيب
الحنون
يعني ما فينا نقول شيء غير حسبنا الله
ونعم الوكيل
عبد القادر خربوش العربيه
جهه عديده انتفضت لتقديم المساعده لضحايا
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا عالم كره
القدم لم يكن بعيدا عن ذلك
عالم كره القدم يهب لمساعده ضحايا الزلزال
[موسيقى]
مع ان يمكننا تحقيق اي شيء في الاوقات
الصعبه
العديد من لاعبي كره القدم انضموا لحمله
بيع قمصان اللاعبين للتبرع بعوائدها
للمنكوبين
خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه بيعت قمصان
لاعبين عالميين مقابل مبالغ كبيره من
بينهم البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو
الارجنتيني
والايطالي ليوناردو بونوتشي
تبرعات ماديه ضخمه قدمها ليونيل ميسي تقدر
بثلاثه ملايين ونصف المليون يورو
فرق كره القدم التركيه هبت بدورها لتقديم
المساعده ابرزها فريق غلطه سراي ونادي
بيشكتاش
خلال زلزال فرانسيسكو عام 1906 تزحزحت
منطقه الزلزال نحو سته امتار وفي تركيا
نفسها تزحزح الاناضول خلال زلزال ازميت
عام 99 اكثر من مترين ونصف واليوم اشرع
علماء جيولوجيا الى ان جانبا من صفيحه
الاناضول تحرك لحوالي ثلاثه امتار لكن كيف
تتحرك الصفائح التكتونيه
زلزال في السادس من فبراير كان ضخما جدا
وفي المناطق المنكوبه من الصعب على
الناجين فهم حجم ما حدث وهذا ما تحدثوا
عنه لكن لفهم ما جرى بالضبط سنتخيل ان سطح
الارض هو عباره عن احجيه عن الطبقه
الخارجيه منها ليست متصله هي مكونه من
صفائح ضخمه تقريبا 20 20 قطعه متداخله مع
بعضها البعض وبنفس الشكل الذي تتخذه
الاحجيات لكنها تستمر في الحركه وببطء
وبمعدل سنتيمتر الى 20 في السنه اما ان
تتباعد او تصطدم ببعضها او تنزلق عبر
حدودها
ما احدث الزلزال الاول وما تلاه منطقيا
كان تحركا عنيفا تمزق على اثره امتداد
الصدع بين صفيحتي الاناضول والعربيه التي
تقع تركيا على خطوطه مع الصفيحه الوراثيه
ايضا تركيا تحركت مشاهدينا بثلاثه امتار
خلال ثواني نعم الجغرافيا تغيرت البلد
باكمله تحرك نحو الغرب
غير او تغير مكانه
ومع وقوع الزلزال المدمر في تركيا وسوريا
يسعى رجال الانقاذ للاستعانه بكل ما يمكن
من حيوانات او ادوات للوصول الى ناجينا
تحت الانقاض لا سيما ان عمليات البحث خلال
هذه الكوارث من اصعب عمليات الانقاذ
واكثرها تعقيدا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الصمت هنا مختلف ليس كاي صمت حتى انه عرف
بصمت الموت فعلى طريق النجاه ينادي
المنقذون بصوت واحد ثم يصمتون جميعا
وسيله استخدمها المنقذون للعثور على
ناجيين في سوريا وعلى قله الامكانيات ولو
كان الامل ضعيفا بوجود انفاس تحت هذه
الانقاض يحاول عمال البحث بطرق بدائيه
وتقليديه
في ظل تعقيد البحث وصعوبه الوصول وسماع
الناجين تحت اقوام الركام تطورت ادوات
البحث لنجده العالقيين فاعتمد الخبراء على
تقنيات تكنولوجيه تطورت عبر الزمن ومن
ابرزها الفئران والصراصير المزوده
بكاميرات صغيره القادره على الدخول الى
امكنه لا يمكن رؤيتها او حتى سماع اصوات
تطلب استغاثه الافعى الروبوت على شكل
ثعبان يستطيع صعود درجات عاليه والتنقل
عبر المساحات الضيقه تقنيه حديثه يسعى
الباحثون لاستخدامها الطائرات المسيره
بامكانها فصل الاحياء عن الاموات عن طريق
الكشف عن حركه بسيطه للضحايا وحده فايندر
تاتي بحجم حقيبه اليد ترسل موجات دقيقه
منخفضه الطاقه ويمكن ان تكشف الموجات عن
خفيه مثل النبض الخفيف للجلد الذي يكشف عن
دقات القلب
سمعناه
مشعلا مصباحه ينادي مسابقا للزمن اعل صوته
ينجح في انقاذ عالق من قبضه تلك الانقاض
بشتى الطرق وباي طريقه كانت يحاول ولا
يزال
عصام عبد السلام العربي
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا سنواصل معكم تغطيهنا للزلزال
لكن نتوقف امام بعض الاخبار الخاصه بملفات
اخرى
اذا نبدا من امريكا حيث اعلن جون كيربي
الناطق باسم مجلس الامن القومي ان البيت
الابيض اكد ان طائره مقاتله امريكيه اسقطت
هدفا فوق الاسكا في الساعه الماضيه باوامر
مباشره من رئيس جو بايدن واوضح كيربي ان
هذا الجسم الذي قال انه بحجم سياره صغيره
شكل تهديدا لامن الملاحه الجويه
دائما يتصرف بالطريقه التي تهدف الى حمايه
مصالح الامريكيين والامن القومي الاسبوع
الماضي تحدثنا عن هدف تم اسقاطه بنجاح بعد
ان حلق فوق الاجواء الامريكيه واليوم ايضا
نتحدث عن هدف لا نعرف تفاصيله لكنه كان
يمثل تهديدا محتملا لسلامه الطيران المدني
بالنظر الى الارتفاع الذي كان يحلق عليه
وجه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو
بتعزيز قوات الامن في منطقه القدس على
خلفيه وقوع هجوم بالدهس اليوم والذي اسفر
عن سقوط قتيلين واصابه سبعه مستوطنين في
راموت بعضهم دخل المراحل الخطره كما وجه
نتنياهو ايضا بالتحرك الفوري لاغلاق منزل
منفذ العمليه وهدمه بالاضافه الى القاء
القبض على الاشخاص ذو الصله بالمهاجم
امر وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اثمر
بنجفير بعمليه امنيه واسعه في القدس
الشرقيه بعد مقتل اسرائيليين في عمليه دهس
اليوم
ونقل تلفزيون اي 23 نيوز الاسرائيلي عن من
فير
القول في بيان ان العمليه ستبدا الاحد
وتهدف الى الوصول الى منازل منفذ الهجمات
بهدف وقفهم قبل تنفيذها وكانت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه اعلنت في وقت سابق مقتل شخصين
واصابه خمسه اخرين في عمليه دهس بسياره
قربى مستوطنه رامون بالقدس المحتله
اصدرت وزاره الاستخبارات والحرس الثوري
الايراني بيانا يفيد باعتقال السلطات
لمنفديه هجوم اصفهان بالطائرات المسيره
وذلك وفقا لوكاله انباء تسنيم الايرانيه
والتي افادت ايضا بان السلطات تعرفت على
اشخاص قالت انهم تابعون لاسرائيل في
الهجوم بطائرات المسيره على احد المراكز
الصناعيه الخاصه بالصواريخ في اصفهان
شهدت مدينه زاهدان عاصمه بلوجستان في
ايران احتجاجات كبيره اليوم عقب صلاه
الجمعه وطلب المتظاهرون باطلاق سراح
السجناء السياسيين في ايران واسقاط النظام
الايراني وقال امام اهل السنه في ايران
مولوي عبد الحميد ان كافه الشعب الايراني
يريد التمتع بحقوق متساويه دون تمييز لاحد
مؤكدا على ان الشعب الايراني انتفض
لادراكه ان المشكله لا يمكن حلها
[موسيقى]
ابلغته وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاثرين
كولونا نظيرها الامريكي
بضروره وجود رد دولي اقوى على تهديد الذي
يشكله برنامج الصواريخ الباليستيه
الايراني الوزيران طالبا طهران بضروره
التعاون الكامل مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه والوفاء
بالتزاماتها النوويه
اعلنت الخارجيه الروسيه ان النشر الصواريخ
الامريكيه التي تفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت في
اليابان يؤثر على الامن والاستقرار
الاستراتيجي في العالم وقالت الناطقه باسم
الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا زهاربا ان روسيا
ستراقب عن كثب اي استعدادات لتنفيذ خطه
واشنطن مؤكده ان تنفيذها سيعني تغييرا في
الامن الاقليمي وكانت تقارير اعلاميه ذكرت
ان الولايات المتحده اقترحت نشره صواريخ
متوسطه المدى في اليابان كجزء من خطه
لتعزيز الدفاعات ضد الصين على طول بحر
الصين الشرقي والجنوبي
حثت النرويج وسويسرا في بيان مشتركين
الاطراف اللبنانيه على السماح باجراء
تحقيق نزيه وشفاف في انفجار مرفا بيروت
والامتناع عن كل اعمال التدخل داعيه مجلس
النواب اللبناني الى الاسراع في انتخاب
رئيس يوحد الشعب اللبناني من اجل المصلحه
الوطنيه كما عبرت عن قلقها ازاء الوضع
الحالي في لبنان
مشاهدينا بهذا تنتهي هذه الساعه ولكن
التغطيه على العربيه مستمره لكارثه
الزلزال الذي ضربت تركيا وسوريا بعد قليل
يستكمل معكم في الساعه التاليه الزميل
ابراهيم بدر